Dole playing Pop G strong player
I do have a plus score against Pap G
I believe this is Ghoulia pop
okay this is gonna be a like very
serious Rabbit game
I think pubg is also a streamer if I'm
not mistaken
higher rated opponent too
I do want to manage my time
I'm using alerts
okay Bishop E5 I was studying this line
like recently
I actually man
I discovered a new idea in this line
and then I I only saw the new idea and I
didn't look further but this is a new
idea C4
it's like a super rare move the engine
just spat it out
and the only thing I know is it's bad
for black to take the bishop
if black takes the bishop I'll have to
figure out why
I meant to prepare this um
more deeply
anyway okay it's cool to get a bit of
opening prep
like a pretty New London idea
I'm provoking my opponent to take their
time
I do remember the engine is giving like
a very slight Edge to to White if black
finds the right line
the E6 I think is the best move
now do I take
probably Bishop G3
I'll have to look at this line in more
depth
yeah it's too bad the bishop wasn't
taken it could have been a fun decision
I'll share after the game what would
happen
so now okay
Knight takes G3 is not played
I could consider this move
I'd like to take with Pawn
keep a pawn in the center
so I'm actually calculating like takes
not sure how great that is for me though
takes 95 takes
takes not sure
I could play C5
is a move
does relieve the pressure on the center
though
C5 Bishop C7
[Music]
takes 95
I think I'll start with C5
it's kind of an intuitive decision
I do make the prospect of E5 a bit more
enticing for Bach
I mean the hope is that I have this 95
move
do I want to play it right away
take first
realizing wait tix takes 95 takes takes
G6
so maybe a bishop B5
yeah
I probably have to Castle
it's going to be a a struggle in the
center like the whole focus is around
this E5 break
I don't think black can play it right
away
but taking verse makes sense
E5 comes
yeah and I don't want to take the
knights
probably a bit worse here
I take
taking looks very bad
but I might have to take
taken then rookie one
now lock has the center and the bishop
pair
taking Queen A4
start by taking
I also take
I don't want to conceive the bishop
though
and queen A4
Queen B3
Queen B3 could be interesting
so the idea is I'm preventing E4 because
Knight takes E4
I might have ideas of Knight E4 like
anyway
and I want to get the Rooks to the
center quickly to pressure the Pawns
the thing is a black adequately depends
upons I'm probably just much worse
but if I can somehow like win a pawn or
provoke a pawn to move and get a Center
Square
maybe it's playable
like rookie one is probably an idea
for example Bishop E6 rookie one
and I'm starting to take the pawn
there's Queen F6 there
it doesn't look good for me
uh
I think my whole idea just fails
unless wait I have this move first
oh my whole idea just fails
because I probably played this move
first
I want to take but Knight A5 is very
very strong
sacking a piece doesn't work
[Music]
yeah not a happy moment
and I want to take again but Rook B
Yates
the tactics are all in Black's favor
so
it's going to be tough to come back here
like even though I'm not down material
it's just such a good position for that
a file there's a six might happen
[Music]
maybe I can resort to some trickiness
like at least there's a target maybe
Queen A4 at some points
The Rook B8 looks playable Rook p8 takes
takes okay
that's also playable
there's so many things to be concerned
about here
the queen C3 runs into this let's play
Queen E3
defending some targets
have a feeling this move is gonna happen
but maybe I'm barely holding things
together
there's a line Knight B3 A5 Rook D1 A4
Knight C1
like Bishop A6 rookie one I want to play
92.
it's possible a lot of my next moves
will be defensive moves
yeah that's strong I'm considering like
second Exchange
B4
I could play Rook D1 immediately
actually
so that if Bishop E5 I have other
options
but now my Queen's tie down to F2 so
just have to be very tactically alert
one plan is b4a4 B5 which
longer possible
rugby one runs into Bishop D3
how do I even defend
B3
B3 Bishop E5
Knight F1
[Music]
an iPhone Bishop D3 wow
I think I'm just losing material
I have Knight B3 right away
that's so ugly though
I'm trying ip3
there's so much pressure here
this was one of my original ideas
problem yeah the problem is basically
five Bishop Z3
how to defend
and Black's position is so strong
would be one
positions like this you just have to
make the opponents like
earn the win
hold on towards your life
this move's coming though
any way to sack
of Knight C2
Knight C2 D4
don't hurt me
if I take Taking doesn't work
what about taking you here
Bishop B1
almost works I have three this would be
one Rook D3 Pawn D3
Knight F3
maybe that's the best try
at least my horsies can find some life
Isaac Exchange
what else to do
Bishop D4 is maybe coming but I have
Queen C1
I'm just trying to hold on to my horses
and practically maybe there's still some
hope
that's a terrifying move
wait can I take
not taking Queen takes
that's so angry
95 doesn't work
it's gonna have four idea
and G5 might be coming
um
and she finds probably coming
or not
I gotta go YOLO like Queen C4 Queen F5
stops it
take
um
nice move
and the salon
take take
oh no my horsey
keep Queens on the board
you never know there's always blunder
possibilities
unlikely though
foreign
I tried to at least create counter play
but the final position was losing
good game
it was fun to try and get this like new
London idea
that I wanted to keep secret for a
little bit longer
opponent uh
I guess it didn't didn't take the bishop
which is a poison piece
uh let's just show the line
that after
that's crazy like when I
I think the way I discovered this line
so I was analyzing a recent game where
my opponent played my H5
I just turned on the engine
and C4 is one of the top moves
oh but it's only after Bishop E5 yeah so
Bishop E5
F6 is the main line
and then here C4 is a top
computer move
which before a few days ago I had never
seen before
um it's only been played a handful of
times
and yeah the best move for back is what
my opponent played
after Z5
so let's see the reason why this isn't
good for black
is white
guts initiative
and after Queen digs D5
Bishop C4
how does this go Queen D6
wow so it's very specific there's
Knights G5 hitting this and threatening
this
maybe this
apparently that's it's enough
compensation for whites
so there's one game between Gupta and
Gandhi
featured Knight B4
Knight takes E5 Knight F6
Bishop B5
Bishop D7
wow so
white doesn't quite win back the piece
but White's just dominating here like
Knight A6 runs into Queen H5 Queen G5
Rook G8 Queen E6
Rook h8 94 threatening mates
threatening two different mates
oh that's a really funny line
so with black like Forks the queen and
Bishop white can choose which checkmates
this is a more ecstatic mage
taking advantage of both pins
so in the one game that featured this
line
black played A6 counter-attacking
and this allows white to win back the
piece after it takes takes and takes
and white has not lost a single Pawn
until the next move
but then after it takes takes
Queen A4 check
the out lights in such good shape I mean
not only up a pawn but
yeah crashing position
so
um
that was maybe what could have happened
in an alternate universe but my opponent
yeah played very solidly upon E6
I played Bishop G3 and after it takes
I should have taken with Knight
yeah that's the type of thing like if I
studied this line way more in depth I
should be prepared here
both moves are playable though
so
I guess in this line the knights could
get traded
ah
this I did not consider it takes in G3
makes some sense
keep the tension
and the knight's kind of out of the play
and C5 was just a positional mistake
I think for the rest of the game I was
worse
yeah
opponent played really well perfect game
a Grand Master Level play
but I think like from the moment I
played C5
if the moves were very natural for lack
I was thinking I'd like I could clamp
down
I initially wanted to play 95 I think in
this line takes takes 95.
but it doesn't work because G6 now I'm
losing D4
did we look at The Rook B2 position
at one moment though
it was pretty
pretty dire situation
after Rook fe8s
oh yeah I mean I wanted to do this but
there's Queen takes
maybe it's the best oh I didn't see the
Knight defense
okay it's still losing so I don't feel
so bad for missing this I didn't realize
my knight can take the queen
so takes takes takes
but it's losing because after I lose a
Pawns
Knights are not good at stopping the
outside passer
anything saving us for Bishop E4 I don't
know what moment that refers to
Pawnee for it was hard to stop on e4
actually
in most of the lines E4 is White's next
move
oh Bishop E5
that's very hard move to stop
if I ever play F4 it's just too
weakening on passan
okay can't be too upsets
I hope people enjoy that one
how a grand master crushes my London
opening
probably put that one on YouTube